In the last lecture we learned how to import
a digital image into a computer and we learned
that an image inside a computer is just a
big bunch of numbers. More precisely it's
a rectangular array of numbers which we can
consider to be a matrix. Now getting the image
into the computer is just the first step.
We need to manipulate this image in various
ways so that we can extract the information
from that image which is sufficient to hand
across to a robot to allow it to do its job.
So in this lecture and the next one, we're
going to learn about some fundamental ways
to transform images so as to help us in the
process of extracting meaning.
These techniques fall into a category which
is called image processing, which is how we
take one image and transform it into a different
image which helps us in our task of extracting
that meaning. So the sorts of transformations
that we would be interested in considering
are; how do we enhance the contrast of an
image? How do we reduce the resolution of
an image? How do we highlight horizontal lines
in an image or how do we highlight vertical
lines in an image? Or how do we highlight
things that are red or that are green or that
are blue. So these are some fundamental techniques
that will help us in our journey of equipping
robots with vision.